[Music]
all good things must come to an end
sadly homo sapiens time on earth
is no exception
and
someone would surely take our place as
the dominant species but
who
or rather
what
how could genetic engineering spell out
the end for our species
what would distinguish the next homo
species from us
and could the world's next dominant
species not be human at all
this is what if and here's what would
happen if homo sapiens went extinct
some of the earliest species of humans
date back at least seven million years
back then different humanoid species
belonging to the hominidae family walked
amongst each other
they evolved interbred and way more
often than not died out
our species homo sapiens arrived on the
scene about six million years ago but it
wasn't until some point in the last
fifteen thousand to forty thousand years
that we emerged as the only living
species of humans
and not long after that we had settled
on every continent except for antarctica
our social innovation and tool creation
are some of the factors you could thank
for this these skills allowed us to out
compete other species like neanderthals
and this innovative nature could be what
leads to our very own demise
when we create a new super human species
that could outlive us all
according to the author don simborg our
successors or homo nouveau would look
more or less just like you
the big difference these humanoids would
be more like a highly engineered version
homo nouveau would be created through
the selective editing of our genes
their genes could be manipulated so that
they grow taller age slower or no longer
contract certain diseases
and should these new humans not
interbreed with us
they could be on their own distinct
evolutionary path
thanks to natural selection they could
start looking and acting differently
from us homo sapiens
now while this could sound like
something out of a sci-fi film
it could be closer than you think
it took modern humans about 200 000
years to evolve from our more archaic
predecessors but homo nouveau could come
into existence in a matter of decades
this could be largely thanks to crispr
and no that's not the hottest new
kitchen appliance it's an acronym for
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats
in other words genetic editing
using this method you could add remove
or alter particular locations in an
organism's dna
you could use it to prevent and treat
diseases by making edits to somatic
cells in your body
these changes you make to your own
genome couldn't be passed on to your
children but should you start tinkering
with the genetic sequences of your eggs
or sperm cells
you could be laying out the red carpet
for our successor species
next-gen crispr created humans could
have genetically modified heights and
muscle masses to go along with their
customized skin hair and eye colors
and over time there could be an
intersection of both natural and
unnatural selection
desirable traits could emerge as
dominant ones
these new humans could digest food
differently be less prone to disease and
be better adapted to the effects of
climate change
they could withstand more extreme
temperatures
be less reliant on nutrients and water
or be more resilient to radiation
this would be a particularly huge
advantage should interplanetary space
travel be common in the future
but things wouldn't necessarily be all
peaches and sunshine for this future
species
dangers and unexpected challenges could
present themselves when we play such a
godlike role in our own evolutionary
path
editing just one gene in a single
individual with the hope of achieving a
specific result could have far-reaching
unintended consequences
and these consequences could then be
inherited by this person's children
and their children's children
now while it may sound fun to manipulate
our physiological characteristics
it wouldn't be so simple to engineer
humans to be more intelligent
there are thousands of genes linked to
your iq and they rely on many complex
interactions
messing around with these genes could
have disastrous outcomes
imagine more and more humans suffering
from behavioral conditions like
tourette's syndrome or attention deficit
disorder
whether on purpose or accidental these
could be encoded by only a few genes
and since these are hereditary they
could be passed on
but then again as gene editing advances
you could also see these disorders
eliminated entirely
these homo nouveau could also combine
their genetically modified traits with
cyborg technologies
they could retrieve information at
lightning speed
enhance their vision with infrared to
see at night or become super soldiers by
hooking themselves up directly to
machines like fighter jets
competing with homo nouveau for survival
would be an increasingly difficult
situation for us mere humans
and eventually it could be the end of us
of course there's always the chance that
a non-human entity could surpass us
before they do
like artificial super intelligence
but
that's a story
for another
what if